[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar welcome back how to address the
decline in hpv vaccination and cervical
screening rates
i am kayleigh bach of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by roche diagnostics
to learn more visit roche.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
david pride md phd professor of
pathology director of molecular
microbiology director of microbiology
university of california san diego
and william carlo phd jd mph assistant
professor in the department of public
health sciences at the penn state
college of medicine
dr pride dr callow you may now begin
your presentation
hello this is william callow assistant
professor of pulley health sciences at
the penn state college of medicine in
hershey pennsylvania
the title of my talk is the past present
and future of cervical cancer screening
the importance of hpv vaccination
the objective of our lectures are
present information about cervical
cancer and hpv vaccine spaties in the
u.s
describe vaccine constituency
and discuss best practices for hp
vaccination and cervical cancer
screening
i want to start saying um
and describing how common is
is hpv there are more than 100 different
hpv types that have been identified
and three out of four sexually
transmitted infections or stis in the
u.s are from hpv
as we speak there are over 80 million
men and women in the u.s who are
currently infected with one or more
strains or types of these vitals
and 70
of all people will be infected with hpv
at some point in their life
so in addition to genital warts hpv
plays a high burden on cancer
and as you can see from this figure
every year in the u.s hpv causes more
than 36 000 cancers and specifically
there are six six of them but i want to
point out to
cervical cancer
in the u.s hpv
causes almost 11
000
cervical cancer among women
and although pharyngeal cancer are the
most common
cancer in the u.s caused by hpv
when you break down the cancer types per
gender
cervical cancer is the most common
cancer for a single gender you can see
that it is over 100
cases per year compared to autophagy
cancer
the good news is that cervical cancer
incidence and mortality rates have
decreased by more than 50 percent over
the past four decades
the bad news is that not all
racial
ethnic minority groups in the us are
experiencing this benefit and you can
see from this
from this figure
the blue bars
reflects or demonstrates incidence rates
and the red bars
shows
rates for mortality and is it very
consistent as you can see in this in
this figure that for three specific
minority groups non-hispanic black
females american indian alaska native
females
and hispanic or latina
they experiencing higher rates of both
mortality and incidents when compared to
non-hispanic whites in the u.s
the good news is that we have a vaccine
that is safe and effective to prevent
hpv infection and hpv cancer and that's
the hpv vaccine and the vaccine is
recommended by the cdc
by trusted national
medical organizations like the american
academy family physicians in the
american academy of pediatrics
in the u.s hp vaccine is recommended for
all adolescents ages 11 or 12 but the
vaccine
can be given as soon as h9
one of the one of the benefits of
receiving the vaccine in younger ages is
that um
younger adolescents they have a stronger
um immune response and also we want to
give the vaccine before they are exposed
to the to the vitals it's equally
important that all vaccines that all the
lessons received the hpv vaccine
including both um boys and girls and all
um um adolescents regardless they their
racial and acne background another good
news is that if there is received
vaccination early ages they only need
two doses if they receive vaccination
they initiate the vaccination
at age 15 or later they would require
three doses instead of two
hpv
has proven to be effective in decreasing
cervical hpv infections and cervical
pre-cancer relations in the us among
females among younger females
and you can see in this in this figure
the top the top
portion of this of this figure is just
showing information
about decreases over time actually over
the last decade for
younger females 71 percent decrease in
terms of cervical hpv infection and a 59
decrease for celical pre-cancer lesions
among young females here in the us
when we compare data about those who are
vaccinated and unvaccinated we have very
good data for oral hpv infections and
the data is also promising it's very
good it's just showing that those people
who have received the vaccine are have
completed the vaccine series depending
on two or three doses depending on their
their their age
they have eighty percent
uh lower hpv infections when compared to
those who have nostalgia vaccinations so
here in the us we're seeing we're seeing
um the the
some promising findings about how hpv
vaccine at the population level um is
helping decrease um cervical hpv
infections and cervical precancellations
among women
very promising as well not only in the
u.s but other countries have a very
aggressive um target or goal to
eliminate
cervical cervical cancer and this is the
case of australia and by eliminating
cervical cancer what they mean is to
they want they want cervical cancer to
become a rare disease
and i want you to to read the um
the information at the bottom of this
news report from 2018 just saying
australia will become the first country
to effectively eliminate cervical cancer
if two things happen um if vaccination
and screening rates are maintained and i
think very very important because both
things go hand by hand in terms of
eliminating or diminishing cervical
cancer not only in australia in other
countries but also here in the u.s and
those two things are celebrated cancer
screening and hpv vaccination
but here in the u.s not everybody is
getting the vaccine as recommended using
this this data here for adolescents age
13 to 17.
you can see on the left side of this
figure this is the percentage of kids
vaccinated i'm running from zero to 100
percent that's that's the graph you can
see there and also at the bottom of the
graph you can see the year from 2006 to
2019. there are three vaccines um
recommended for adolescents in the u.s
and those vaccine protects that those
those those vaccines are the ones
showing in this in this figure at the
top of the figure you see a
a blue um solid line that um that lines
represent
vaccination rates for tdap in the in the
us the next line is very close to the
first line the second line is the
vaccine to protect against meningitis
and as you can see in 2019
uh both vaccines reach almost a 90
percent of vaccination right in the
country for this for these adolescents
so this is pretty good because the
national goal
is 80 80 of of vaccination however if
you go a little bit lower in this figure
the third line kind of in the middle is
hpv up to the vaccination for for for
hpv
and i mentioned before um
depending on your age you will require
two or three doses of the of the vaccine
so up today is a measure combining both
if they need two or three doses
so you can see in 2019 vaccination rates
for hpv were a little bit over 60
percent that means two things
number one
that we're 20
points below the national goal of 80
percent and also
that compared to tdap aminogenic
vaccines
hpv is 30
points lower than the over two vaccines
so meaning that parents are going to see
doctors
but there are not accepting hpv vaccine
despite they're accepting the over the
over two vaccines required for school so
this means that there's many
opportunities to increase hp vaccination
here in the u.s the reason for for this
is vaccine assistance
and you can read the definition of
vaccine accidents here
for the who but it's quite important
that we understand the um spectrum of
vaccine ascendancy there's
we have i think we have simplified this
conversation
in the u.s and other countries about if
you're anti-vaccine or pro-vaccine
um but but vaccines have have uh uh by
vaccine accidency
has changed over time and and kobe 19
has changed the way that we think about
considency and refusal and it's
important to understand that there's no
um side versus the other parents and
adults um they can they they they have a
lot of attitudes that are not in those
um different extremes there are people
with honest questions and concerns and
because they're not sure about getting
one vaccine because they have those
concerns you cannot classify in one way
or the other and i will show you some
examples of that in in a moment i really
like this um this table is a paper
polish almost 10 years ago
an issue what i was explaining to you
the categorization of attitudes toward
vaccines or vaccine confidence and
accidency in this in this spectrum or
these five categories
the most important thing here is just to
say as you can see at the bottom of this
figure of this table i'm sorry refusers
usually
they're between three to five percent um
people who actively reject vaccines all
vaccines you know there's no information
that can convince these people
the good news is that almost 97 percent
of the population um they will accept
vaccines
depending their communications and let
me let me go um for each one of these
different buckets or type of patterns in
terms of the vaccine attitudes um
what they mean or they believe about
vaccines and what kind of interventions
you can deliver
to reach or target each one of these
specific type of buttons
so um let's start with the first to be
the first two with the first two groups
the immunization advocates
and they go along to it alone
type of button so the first one they
actively seek vaccinations they demand
vaccination they go to clinic basis
knowing i want to get the vaccine for
for my children and the second group of
parents what is called the go alone to
get along um they agree that vaccines
are safe they're not going to clinic
basis knowing that their child is due
for a particular vaccine that date
but if the vaccine is recommended by
their doctors or medical team they will
follow that advice and they will get the
vaccine so the important thing with
these two type of patterns is that we
have to deliver interventions
that do not raise concerns
that do not already exist among these
these these two groups so the most
important thing is again is just
announce that the vaccine is too and let
them parents know that childhood age are
due for some vaccines and they will they
will get the vaccine okay with some of
them with that small reminder some of
them they're actively sacrificing so you
don't have any problem with this type of
patterns in terms of in terms of their
communication needs then we can move to
the third category and as you can see
there's another 25
of patterns in this in this group here
and so what we call the cautious
acceptor these patterns have some
concerns about vaccines but this is the
good news
they will vaccinate they will get they
will get the vaccine
after their questions or concerns are
answered in a satisfactory way
so that means that all although these
people
have some questions they will accept the
vaccine if you as a clinician
can deliver effective messages to to
them then we are going to the last two
two groups in this in these categories
um including fence leaders these people
have serious concerns about vaccines
they're very uncertain in their vaccine
decisions they're also very important to
target in vaccine communication
especially during clinical encounters
but i'll tell you two things about this
type of products you have to be prepared
to engage in longer discussions or
compensate conversations with them
different from the cautious acceptor
that a brief message would be enough to
convince them with this type of button
defense leader you may need to
expand um your your um
your communication with then give more
information
and sometimes has to happen outside the
clinic business so you have to be ready
to continue this conversation in future
visits it's okay that some of them will
not get the vaccine but the very
important thing is to
um remind yourself in the in the chart
that this
particular pattern or adult reject
vaccination um the reasons why and then
you address the same issue in future
basis and lastly we have the refuses i
mentioned overall depending on the
country you will see something between
three to five percent with the pandemic
the number half increased likely yeah
that's something that that we are aware
this is the most challenging um um
type of buttons or adults to to reach
the most important thing here is that
they will not get the vaccine they will
actively reject all vaccines but it's
important that you build trust these
people have they they have a large
distrust in the scientific community and
the medical community at all so it's
it's important that over time you
continue building this trust you don't
know 5-10 years down the road they will
get vaccines for themselves or maybe
vaccine for your own children
um so again i want to recap something
very important that i mentioned it's
quite important that we depolarize these
these these conversations about prop
versus anti
vaccination positions because i show you
in the prior slides um yes there are two
extremes of people who actively seek
vaccines and people who actively free
your vaccines but they're in the middle
sandwich in the middle there's 70 almost
70 percent of parents who have some
concerns or need some advice or guidance
to get this to get this this this
vaccine hpv and other vaccines overall
um it's equally important that you
identify strategies to address questions
and concerns without without judgement
um the due dal patterns that you are
listening to their concerns and then you
provide effective messages for some of
these patterns short messages will work
pretty well but some other patterns you
will need to provide
more information as you understand where
those questions and concerns are coming
from
and lastly
it is important that you understand and
identify what best practices exist
so you can approach parents where they
are in their in terms of their in their
communication needs and i'll show you
two examples about effective um and
evidence-based practices that i have
been using my prior research one at the
clinic setting is called the
announcement approach and the second one
is through social media and health
promotion campaigns
so let's start with the one that i use
in clinics it's called the announcement
approach the announcement approach uh
basically says two things we should
start announcing um
very briefly that the child is due for
hpv vaccine and other vaccines do at
that age so basically you three things
when you do this announcement you know
the child's age
you announce that children this age are
due for vaccine that prevents several
diseases including hpv cancers and you
say
that the child will get the vaccine
today or at the end of that visit and an
example of how this type of announcement
will look like is something like this
now that sophie is 11 she is due for
three vaccines today she will get
vaccines against meningitis hpv cancers
and whooping cough a good number of
patents
will get the
vaccine by just saying a simple
five second statement like like the one
that i just mentioned especially those
patterns were in the first two
categories that i just described a
moment a moment ago so a good number of
them almost fifty percent of patterns
will get hpv vaccine by just saying
something as simple and short as this
however some patents as i mentioned will
hesitate will show some
some
some concerns and that's okay you have
to do three things here in this second
step first you will be connecting with
them you will ask the patent for the
main concern
and you're showing the pattern that
you're listening something like oh can
you tell me more about the reason you
don't want to get the vaccine today so
in that way when you move to the next
step the clarify step
you use research tested message to
address that specific concern is the
question is about
safety or side effects there's no reason
to
uh bring information about sexual
activity or vice versa the question is
about sexual activity there's no reason
to talk about safety or side effects
or vaccination guidance and so and so
because you are just directing the
conversation to address what that's what
but the the main point
of of of of of um
um to be addressing the communication
needs for this button and lastly you
cancel you give a reason uh you give a
reason to um to vaccinate uh my team and
others we have been working for the past
seven eight years
testing uh messages that providers can
use to address these questions and
concerns that patents may have and we
just publish a paper with um the seven
most common responses based on seven
common questions and concerns that
patterns may have um and these are
starting point conversations you can you
can you can you can use this in your
clinic and then you can elaborate
depending if a pattern continues showing
some distress or
or or is not convinced by the
information that you can provide but as
i mentioned for most parents who show
some hesitation i'm concerned
these brief messages will be will be
enough okay the the or the other type of
intervention that i want to show you is
this one here
and i have been i have been working
um with many um cancer survivors who
have been diagnosed with hpv cancers in
the past
to record film their stories and use
that in clinical settings the video that
you will show here is from jeff jeff
wants his story to be disseminated so
our parents learn about what happened to
him so motivate them to get the vaccine
i know this talk is about cervical
cancer screening um most of the videos
that i have been developing in the past
year focus on autophagy cancer that's
that's a that's a story they were here
in a moment but my team is just working
to create similar stories and identify
women who would like to share their
speeding with cervical cancer so other
um families with um
with girls can benefit from this type of
intervention so let's listen to jeff for
the next three minutes and a half
i'm jeff i'm 63 and grew up in a little
town called boiling springs pennsylvania
i couldn't breathe very well through my
right nostril so i went to the doctor
actually i scheduled to go to the doctor
and about
two days before the appointment
a gland swelled up in my neck about half
the size of a golf ball
so i went to the doctor they looked at
it had me go to get a scan and
then sent me to a specialist head neck
specialist
and there i was diagnosed with
stage four hpv
cancer head and neck cancer
so it was multiple places in my neck
in my
right nostril
behind the base of skull
after you get your scans and they do the
evaluation
and they determine what kind of
treatment you're going to have it's
pretty much 35 days of radiation and
three or four rounds of chemo
i started at 220 pounds
after it was all said and done about
four months later i was 160 pounds so i
lost
60 pounds during the process
um
to get the radiation you have to have a
mask made and it's a it's a wet mask
with holes in it and they put it on your
face and neck and then it molds to your
head
and it molds very close
very close and the reason for that
is because when you have the radiation
treatment they want to be very precise
and so this mask when it dries
you lay on a table and they clip you
down onto the table so you can't move
and that's very important so they they
try to minimize any
damage to good cells so they want to
just focus on the bad cells
it's not a good thing for your
caregivers in this case my wife and
daughter
to watch this slow
slow process
it's um
the sunburn skin skin in my case skin
fell off
so it's regrowing new skin
and the mouth burns and
life changes um especially
radiation really affects your swallowing
and it
pretty much
damages all your
salivary glands
so you have dry mouth for the rest of
your life
severe dry mouth
you have to drink water or something
when you eat or you can't get it down
it wakes you up
about every two three hours you can't
get a full night's sleep
[Music]
it makes you re-evaluate your life
uh for me i had a recurrence after two
years
and it showed up my right lungs so
we ended up going to a clinical trial
and i went through that for two years
and that
i was very fortunate i had 100 response
to that so i'm at the moment cancer free
if you're considering getting the hpv
vaccine i would recommend it
you really don't want to
be treated for this particular cancer
[Music]
again although this this particular
story is not about cervical cancer i
want to share that with you because i
think um it's quite important that um we
use this type of storytelling
intervention
to convince parents of adolescence
about the dangers of not getting the the
hpp the hp vaccine and also mention my
team is just identifying um a woman who
would like to chart similar stories but
with cervical cancer
in order to develop similar videos um to
be deployed in our primary care clinics
in in pennsylvania and the video that i
just showed to you is is going to be uh
it is available for free so if anyone
who is interested to use that for your
um
clinic or any of your interventions you
are more than free to just send me an
email and i'll share that with you
without any problem um one last thing is
that hp vaccination dropped during the
pandemic and
but important very important point
um the largest gap is in vaccines
primarily given to adolescents and more
particularly vaccination fell by three
to four million doses during the kobe 19
pandemic or equivalent to 25 drop
compared to 2019
so i think there's a lot of work that we
have to do
in order to
um um
bring vaccination rates where they were
two three years ago and and lastly the
spread of pakistanis information makes
ongoing vaccine promoting efforts more
challenging so i think it's equally
important that interventions like this
one that we can deploy in social media
are easily available to correct
misinformation that is available and at
the same time occupy that space so
misinformation is not available and
spread um widely um so as a takeaway
when i say use cervical cancer spraining
and hvaccination are important for
cancer prevention and control uh um are
very important transformation control
tools and uh both things need to be used
simultaneously if we want to eliminate
or eradicate
cervical cancer in the us or worldwide
um if you're a clinic staff recommend
you vaccination using the announcement
approach with every single patient that
that you that you can see
and be creative using information and
technology to educate about cervical
cancer screening and hpv
vaccination there are uh many of these
similar stories that i showed you a
moment ago that are available through
the american cancer society among cancer
patients that you can use for cervical
cancer breast cancer in other cancers as
well as the one that i just showed you a
moment ago we will say thank you so much
and you have my email if you have any
any question uh we have a q a at the
very end of this um lecture so feel free
to um
ask me any question or send me an email
thank you so much
thank you so much for your attention i'm
dr david pride i'm going to talk to you
guys today about hpv or human
papillomavirus testing
and i'm going to talk about it a little
bit in the context of
vaccinations
the risks for acquiring hpv and in
particular what happened during the
pandemic
largely in the year 2020
so
as we get started
i want to start with my disclaimers so
first i have been a consultant for roche
in the past i currently am a consultant
for cepheid and i have been a consultant
for hologic
many of whom
do perform
uh hpv testing
so the goals for this webinar so first
i'd like to discuss really the
importance of hpv testing
then we want to
provide an overview
of the approach that can be taken to hpv
testing with a particular emphasis on
identifying high-risk genotypes
also
who should be tested in terms of both
males and females
and then to discuss a little bit
about the testing protocols that can be
used
we want to put particular emphasis on
the impact of the
early pandemic in the year 2020
on trends that we saw in hpv testing and
then we want to end up talking a bit
more about uh vaccinations and how uh
the lack that we saw vaccinations could
potentially impact hpv
and hpv associated diseases in the years
to come
so what is hpv
so hpv is human papilloma virus it's a
small
non-enveloped dna virus
it does have the potential to cause
long-term infections
although i think what is probably lesser
known is that hpv does have the
potential to cause short-term infections
that can and in essence resolve on their
own but when we think about hpv and what
we worry about hpv what we really worry
about are those long-term infections
hpv
generally is spread through sexual
contact it may also be spread through
sustained skin to skin contact
and there is the possibility that it
could spread via formites although
that's not believed to be
a way in which it commonly is spread so
for example hpv is not something you
would expect to get if you sat on the
toilet
and someone
for example
with hpv had sat on that toilet before
you
it is the most common sexually
transmitted infection in the world
there are over 170 different types of
hpv that have been described to date
and hpv is known to cause a couple of
different types of diseases
probably one of the more common thing
is
warts and
while warts can be very unsightly um the
warts in general are not what we worry
so much uh with hpv about
what we worry the most about with hpv
are the fact that it's associated with
several different types of cancers and
those include cervical cancer or
pharyngeal cancer and other types of
squamous cell
carcinomas
we've known for many years now
that hpv is associated with cervical
cancers and it doesn't matter really
what part of the world you look in
most studies basically show the same
thing and that is that the overwhelming
majority of cervical cancers are indeed
associated with long-term hpv
infections
so as i sort of had mentioned uh hpv uh
there are different types that people
can get um the types six and eleven uh
are very very commonly associated uh
with the presence of warts and as i
mentioned while they're unsightly
they're not really what we worry so much
about with hpv
what we worry about are the high risk
genotypes in particular genotypes 16 and
18 although there are many other at
least 14 other high-risk genotypes
that many of the hpv tests nowadays do
evaluate
for
so we know we should be testing for hpv
and the large reason that we want to
test for hpv is one it's a sexually
transmitted infection we want to
decrease sexually transmitted infections
but of course it is a strong cause of
cervical cancers and other types of
cancers as well and we want to
significantly reduce
those individuals in our population that
get diagnosed with cancers so as part of
hpv testing there uh um you could test
both men and women
unfortunately with men the there is no
routine screening that is recommended uh
and we'll kind of get to uh in a second
why there is no routine uh screening
but there is high risk screening uh uh
in particular uh individuals uh at risk
for
throat cancer
or pharyngeal cancer as well as anal
cancers as well and in general screening
for those individuals
tends to be institution uh specific so
there
isn't really right now any universal
guidelines uh for the screening
screening in women is probably a bit
less complicated uh in general because
of the concern for cervical cancer
so uh
there are multiple different ways to
screen for cervical cancer
one of the ways
can be hpv testing alone particularly in
women aged 30 to 65 who can get an hpv
test
basically once every five years as a
screening tool
against cervical cancer as we mentioned
the overwhelming majority of cervical
cancers are associated
with hpv so it's a reasonable thing to
do women may also get
cytology from routine pap smears
and in general when those pap smears are
abnormal oftentimes uh
those women will have hpv testing uh
anyway
so to reduce hpv transmission and that's
uh one thing uh in general that's very
important to know
so while things like condoms and even
gloves
during things like sexual uh contact uh
may be recommended
it's important to know that
you can reduce
the spread via condoms and gloves just
like you can reduce the spreads of many
other sexually transmitted infections
one thing to know in particular about
hpv is that while it doesn't typically
go through condoms um and or through
gloves it can go around them um so it's
certainly not a hundred percent uh
protection and that's the one thing to
know
it's important it's useful
but it's certainly not going to protect
you a hundred percent against the
potential for an hpv infection
so while there's no routine screening
recommended for men for hpv there's
plenty of routine screening recommended
for women when it comes to vaccinations
against hpv
the absolute recommendation is for
vaccinations for both males and females
and the large part is you know we talked
a bit about cervical cancer
but
men can be
extraordinary vectors to spread hpv to
women so if you were only vaccinating
women against hpv there would still be
plenty of men out there
acquiring hpv infections and
transmitting those infections uh
to women so it's important to focus on
both men and women when it comes to hpv
vaccination
right now it's recommended to start
vaccinations between ages 9
and 13. there are multiple different hpv
vaccinations available
such as the gardasil 9 which
has protection against multiple
different types both low risk and high
risk types
of hpv so for example we talked about
type 6 and 11 being responsible for
genital
warts those are included in the gardasil
vaccine
as we talked about type 16 and 18 being
associated uh with cervical and other
types of cancers
and those are included in the vaccine
and it's important to know
in those individuals who are vaccinated
um you can
significantly reduce genital warts by
about 90
as well as associated cancers by about
90
uh as well so it's very very important
to
administer these hpv
vaccines if someone's already infected
with hpv so for example
say a woman already has a chronic
infection with hpv type 16
it's not going to help to get the
vaccination
at that point meaning that
because the vaccination has hpv type 16
you're not going to for example clear
that infection just because you get the
vaccine the goal is to prevent that
infection one point though that i would
make um is that you can get multiple
different hpv uh infections
so that
there's some potential if you've got 16
um to prevent getting 18 or prevent
getting
type 33 for example on top of that 16 so
it's not a complete lack of benefit um
for getting a vaccination
in someone who may already have an hpv
infection
so the role of the clinical lab is
really important uh in hpv uh infection
and we don't oftentimes think that much
about the clinical lab and part of that
is that the clinical lab doesn't have
uh actual contact uh with the patients
uh
involved in the testing
but you know i can tell you as a
clinical laboratory director um the
pandemic
really uh
stressed us quite a bit and not just
from a testing for covid um perspective
but also in terms of testing for all
these other sexually transmitted
infections such as hpv it was a struggle
to get called the test but what i think
a lot of people don't know is it was
also a struggle to get the other tests
like hpv tests
as well and part of that is that you
know a lot of companies were shifting
their manufacturing to covet tests and
away from a lot of the other
types of tests so those tests were also
in short supply uh and the one thing
that we uh
that actually really helped us out quite
a bit was the decreased demand um so the
fact that you know there were
stay-at-home orders and people weren't
getting tested for a lot of sexually
transmitted infections
it's bad for the patient it really was
you know because you know diseases like
gonorrhea chlamydia and hpv continue to
spread through the population
in some ways it was good for clinical
labs just because uh quite frankly we
wouldn't have been able to test to hold
the people in the midst of the tsar's
covey ii uh pandemic because we just
simply didn't have enough supplies uh to
be able uh to do so so we were
constantly faced with the question of
who do we prioritize how do we
prioritize uh testing and it's not just
something that happened to us it
happened really all across
the united states
so the pandemic particularly in the year
2020 had significant impact on sexually
transmitted uh infections it did on hpv
it did on gonorrhea it did on syphilis
it did on chlamydia as well what you
guys are looking at really is um the
percentage of uh of tests compared to
the previous year uh particularly
positive tests and we can see
they're just way down
in the year 2020 um and all of that
really is due to
change in some behaviors uh in
particular change in going to see
doctors uh during the earlier parts of
the pandemic
so
we
attract our testing at our institution
during the uh pandemic we saw
significant decreases in volumes of many
of our tests across the year 2020
particularly when it came to sexually
transmitted infections we saw fewer
chlamydia gonorrhea tests we solved
fewer hiv tests we saw fewer uh
hepatitis b we saw fewer syphilis
tests we now have basically returned to
baseline or to what we expect to be but
there was a significant impact in the
year 2020 and it's uh likely an impact
that the patient populations uh will be
observing for years to come and
particularly for hpv
um
according to our sort of charting
we expected to see about 8 800 hpv tests
uh in the year 2020. we only saw 7 400
hpv tests
that is a significant decline we didn't
see any declines in the positivity rates
we just saw declines in the number of
people uh who are tested so
to some extent hpv um
was uh uh likely spreading undiagnosed
uh in our patient population during that
time period and that's just something
that we have to deal with on the back
end now
while our volumes weigh down the uh
volumes of uh screening uh for cancers
in california in general we're down by
about eighty percent um so uh um we uh
we believe our harbinger for the rest of
the united states meaning that uh
testing was down all across the board
particularly when it comes to hpv
particularly when it comes
to uh to cancer screening uh as well uh
and most of that's due to the pandemic
the limitations on supply as well as
just to decrease uh doctor visits that
we saw during that uh time period so
again we saw testing impacted really
across the board and it was not widely
publicized that we had such uh
impacts or decreases in our testing
potential during that time and we kind
of thank goodness that it wasn't widely
uh
publicized because we were able to get
all of our testing done um but if
testing had been uh in essence about 100
uh of what it had been the year before
we would not have been able to get all
of that done
and the
most important part particularly as it
comes to hpv and sexually transmitted
infections is that we now know a lot of
the same behavior
um that led to sexually transmitted
infections continued during that part of
the pandemic we just simply weren't
making uh the diagnoses uh any anymore
we saw significant decreases again in
doctor visits uh during that time
particularly in the year
2020
and we saw significant decreases in hpv
vaccinations throughout that time um so
as we you know i had sort of already
mentioned right how we impact hpv um our
best tool probably is the vaccination
and we saw vaccinations uh
really significantly decline in the year
2020 and we need to catch up with that
um but uh during that time there's
probably plenty of unvaccinated people
uh who probably acquired hpv infections
and again we won't be able to just give
them the vaccinations to eradicate that
infection once they have that infection
um it's potentially uh long-term
infections in at least some portion of
those uh patients
as i mentioned we we had a consumable
problem uh meaning that we didn't have
the things we needed to do
to test for sexy transmitted infections
that's something that was a trend all
across the united states um uh and in
particular when it comes to sexually
transmitted infections those are greater
than for a lot of other uh tests uh that
are out there and if we just track it
basically month over month all of our
testing consumables um while we've made
it back to baseline now particularly in
the year 2022 we can basically get what
we need thanks to uh the manufacturing
of a lot of the uh the companies uh
during the year 2020 um there were
severe shortages of a lot of
things necessary
to conduct all of our testing including
sexy transmitted infections and
particularly
hpv
so
there were a lot of people who uh were
uh have been impacted by thesaurus kovi
ii uh pandemic um and really we've seen
it overall all across the country it
doesn't matter what part of the country
you're in uh that has been impacted uh
significantly the one thing that uh
we may not pay nearly as much attention
to
is that not
every region or every part of the
country is affected equally and myself
at a large academic institution we were
able to continue our testing throughout
most uh of the pandemic
our institution was able to continue to
provide vaccinations
even though demand was uh was lower
during that time
but a lot of minority particularly
underserved communities and rural
communities that don't have large
hospitals that were able to access
testing supplies that they needed um
unfortunately may have gotten the short
end of the stick uh during the uh the
pandemic and that's something that it
probably will take us a little while to
sort of dig ourselves out from
so just in conclusion
hpv testing can be a critical part of
our diagnostics to reduce cervical and
other types of cancers we know that
testing dropped significantly due to the
pandemic in 2022 um that a large part of
that uh
was the testing supplies were also uh
diminished uh in uh 2020
as well and accompanying the fact that
testing drop testing supplies drop it
was also to decrease demand for hpv
vaccinations uh along that same
time course and there certainly is the
potential that the lack of testing the
lack of vaccinations uh it's probably
gonna lead to more chronic hpv
infections and the potential for an
increase in hpv-related cancers in the
years to come
so thank you so much for attending today
um i really appreciate everyone
that came to hear us talk a little bit
about hpv testing so now i'll turn it
back over thank you
[Music]
thank you dr pride and dr callow for
your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question asks have you seen an increase
in hpv vaccination rates screening rates
in 2022
hello this is this is william can you
hear me
yes i can yeah um
the data for 2021
in terms of hp vaccination and other
adolescent vaccines um
it is expected to be released very soon
usually lacks like like like a full year
um so we will have information about
state regional and national data
hopefully very soon in terms of 2021
in terms of 2022 this this year i can
tell you their own experience of our
institution penn state college of
medicine and penn state health we're
seeing an increase in wellness visits as
schools are resuming in person um
education and
and and people are more comfortable
going to doctor offices so we're seeing
an increase in wellness business i can i
don't have information about it that is
if that translates to more vaccines
given during those visits but at least
we're having more kids coming to our or
to our own offices
great thank you
next question here asks should we test
the oropharynx of women with high-risk
hpv cervical infections how about their
partners oropharynx or urethra and semen
so uh i'm i'm happy to take that uh that
question you know in general uh right
now there we don't have routine and
screening recommendations for for
example for the oropharynx and uh many
of the tests for hpv that are available
uh in fact are not validated for use in
the oral pharynx
however there are many institutions
really across the country that are
validating their tests to be used to
make uh hpv diagnoses from the both the
oral pharynx as well as from the anal
rectal areas uh as well
and i think that that's going to be a
continued trend so that something like
uh screening uh of the oral pharynx or
even the uh anal areas will in fact be
possible um most of what we're targeting
in terms of uh that sort of screening
tend to be relatively high risk people
and of course anyone that is symptomatic
but i do think over the course of maybe
the next five to ten years we'll start
to see more of that take place
great thank you dr pride
next question here for adults who miss
childhood vaccination can they be
vaccinated and how many doses
the answer is jess and they would
require three doses the most important
thing is that for those up to age 26 um
they can go and get the
vaccine in their
primary care office and but if they are
between the age of 27 to 45 they have to
have a conversation
with their doctor to better understand
if it's beneficial for them to get the
vaccine so the vaccine can be um can be
received but um depending on the age
it is recommended but for some of those
um adults between ages 27
um to 45 they would need to have a
conversation first
great thank you looks like we have time
for a few more questions here
next one asks if a male does not present
warts is there a way to test or excuse
me is there a test to determine if he is
infected with hpv
yeah and and unfortunately that's uh uh
really a fairly complicated question to
uh to ask um or to answer and part of
the reason is that we don't for example
have great antibody tests for hpv and
the reason is that there are so many
different types of hpv that it's very
very difficult to develop an antibody
test
for example to determine have you been
exposed or do you uh for example
currently have hpv what we do uh in
particular for certain of our male
populations is that we do in fact screen
them uh both their uh oropharyngeal as
well as their anal rectal areas uh for
the presence of hpv and we do that based
on certain uh patient behaviors um
with uh testing individuals for example
who don't have warts uh is is a bit
difficult because the question becomes
well what do you screen um so a healthy
female it's kind of obvious right you
screen the cervic uh the cervical area
uh in a male there's no sort of
great analog for the cervical area so
the question is uh can you swab the
penis we tend not to because it tends to
be very very uncomfortable um and the
question becomes well can we at some
point in the future screened urine
we're certainly not there yet in terms
of screening urine for males
but that might be a sample type that we
might think about
that could be possible at some point in
the future but it's not something that's
available
and certainly not widely right now
great thank you dr pride looks like we
have time for one more question here and
dr callow this is directed towards you
this asks do you think that the covet
vaccination hesitancy has led to hpv
vaccine resistancy
yeah and i will i'll i'll say that
vaccine is a it evolved over time
but i want to connect two of those
vaccines um i mean i'll do this to these
two issues hpv and and and kobe 19.
some of the
stories that we know are misinformation
especially in the in the in the topic of
hp vaccination
it is infertility that um
many patents believe that if they get
the vaccine their
their
one of the side effects will be future
infertility if you look at the one of
the
primary misconceptions about kobe 19 is
exactly that one okay especially among
pregnant and postpartum woman and i'm
working with some of them right now um
understanding also their stories filming
their stories in order to educate their
peers about why they should get the kobe
19 vaccine so what we're seeing is a lot
of the
same misinformation
has been replicated for kobe 9 most of
the misinformation for hpv has been
replicated or expanded also to kobe 19
vaccination and vice versa so i i think
it's going to be a little bit difficult
um to disentangle misinformation for
both vaccine or for any other vaccines
moving forward
the most important thing is to develop
interventions that help us you know to
to talk with with parents and families
in the clinical setting as i mentioned
also in my presentation you know occupy
those spaces for example in social media
we should be more proactive on um
identifying misinformation providing
accurate information or correcting that
misinformation so i think there's a lot
of things that we can that that that
that we can do that can serve for
both vaccines copy 19 and hpv and it can
serve for for more of of the overall
vaccine residency that we're seeing
right now
great well thank you again dr pride and
dr calla for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor roche
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye
you